guten Tag da sind wir heute herzlich
Willkommen zu heute ist kaum zu glauben
aber in zehn Tagen startet bereits die
Fußball-WM in Katar wo dann 32
Mannschaften um den Titel spielen werden
so mancher Nationaltrainer hat seinen
Kader schon bekannt gegeben nicht so der
unsere hansi-flick macht das nämlich in
wenigen Minuten und das ist der Grund
warum wir heute mit euch hier zusammen
sind wir gucken nämlich auf die Kader
Bekanntgabe 26 Mann dafür nominieren
viele Spieler gelten im Vorfeld bereits
als gesetzt aber er hat auch angekündigt
haben sie fliegt dass er die eine oder
andere Überraschung dabei haben wird wir
sprechen später bei uns in der Sendung
mit Felix casalino er ist Fußballer in
der Regionalliga West spielt für die SG
Wattenscheid 09 außerdem Mitglied des
youtube-kanals freekickers mit knapp 9
Millionen Abonnenten einer der
erfolgreichsten in Deutschland eher
später bei uns und ich freue mich
zunächst mal über die fachkundige
Unterstützung hier im Studio mein ZDF
Sport Kollege Thomas gulski nämlich ist
bei uns
das machen wir doch herzlich willkommen
Thomas schön dass du bei uns bist in
welcher Rolle genau wirst du die WM
verfolgen ich werde vom Beginn an da
sein für Interviews schalten aus den
Stadien Einschätzungen der Spiele vorher
und nachher also wirst vor Ort in Katar
sein
reden wir vielleicht gleich ganz kurz
ich meine wir wollen in erster Linie
heute um sportliche oder über das
sportliche sprechen aber weil du eben
auch nach Cutter fährst und man kommt an
dem Aspekt einfach nicht vorbei es gibt
große Diskussionen ob das also nein das
ist vergossene Milch die WM wurde
dorthin vergeben aber es gibt eben
gerade wieder doch die Schlagworte
Menschenrechte Homophobie mit welchen
Gefühlen fährst du zu diesem Turnier
jetzt komplett mit gemischten Gefühlen
also
irgendwie in der Zwickmühle in der ich
noch nie war also ich bin seit 1994 bei
Welt und Europameisterschaften vor Ort
um zu einem beklemmenden Gefühl bin ich
da noch nie noch nie hingefahren und
natürlich kann man die Entscheidung
jetzt nicht rückgängig machen die ist
vor 12 Jahren getroffen worden im
Dezember 2010 heute würde sie sicherlich
nicht so fallen man muss es jetzt neben
die Frage ist warum war der Widerspruch
in diesen zwölf Jahren nicht viel viel
größer da hat Jochen Breyer in seinem
Film sehr interessante Fakten dazu
geliefert und jetzt finde ich müssen was
hinnehmen man sollte und will auch den
Fußball gucken aber wenn wir vor Ort
sind ich will nicht der couchkritiker
sein sondern ich will dann auch vor Ort
gehen und gucken wie es wirklich ist
verstehe weil du es angesprochen hast
die zdf-doku Geheimsache Kata die ist
natürlich auch bei uns in der Mediathek
noch zu sehen jetzt kriege ich ein
achtung auf meinem Ohr wir gehen direkt
zur PKW sprechen über alle weiteren
Aspekte dann noch mal später haben sie
Flick hat bereits Platz genommen los
geht's
die erste
ja-nominierung kardan-nominierung für
eine WM als dann letztendlich der der
hier vorne steht und das auch dann euch
auch mitteilen darf aber wir haben uns
am Dienstag getroffen das heißt meine
Co-Trainer Markus Sorg und Danny Röhl
wir haben viele Dinge durchgespielt ja
wenn dann Strategien auch durchgegangen
wir haben gedanklich auch so mehrere
Dinge die ihm passiert Spiel passieren
können durchgespielt und haben natürlich
auch dann einfach überlegt okay wer kann
der Mannschaft helfen wer ist vielleicht
für die ein oder andere Situation für
uns der match-spinner und
haben uns das ganze nicht einfach
gemacht
wie ihr mit Sicherheit alle auch
verstehen könnt ist es natürlich für
viele Spieler oder für einige Spieler
und eine Sache die wenn sie dann nicht
dabei sind ja einfach nicht ganz so toll
und deswegen ist es auch kann ich
wirklich sagen haben wir uns das auch
nicht einfach gemacht das heißt abends
kam dann Oliver Bierhoff noch dazu weil
wir mit ihm natürlich auch immer wieder
die Dinge besprechen wir haben guten
Austausch und deswegen war es uns auch
wichtig dass Oliver dann dabei war und
dann war gestern so im Laufe des Tages
kam dann alle Trainer dazu und da haben
wir alles noch mal vorgestellt und haben
gesagt okay unsere Gedanken noch mal
mitgeteilt und
dann einfach noch offen diskutiert und
dann am Ende ist es einfach so dass wir
dann gemeinsam auch entschieden haben
wer dann dabei ist wenn die 26 Spieler
sind und glaube wir haben wissen sehr
guten Kader den man mitnehmen können und
von daher ist es für uns natürlich auch
wie ich eine Sache wo wir uns freuen
aber ist natürlich auch wirklich ich
glaube jeder von uns der hier im Raum
ist hat manche Dinge auch mitbekommen
was was in Katar oder von Katar Seite
dann passiert ist was uns sprachlos
macht fassungslos das ist in der
heutigen Zeit einfach einfach so
passiert also ich glaube es ist enorm
wichtig dass wir
dass ich als DFB auf der einen Seite
natürlich auch die Spieler ganz klar uns
auf den Sport ja das würde die Chance
auf den Sport zu konzentrieren aber klar
auch ansprechen müssen was die
Menschenrechtssituation in Katar vor Ort
auch ist und da müssen wir unsere Augen
unsere Ohren aufhalten und ich glaube
das ist das ist letztendlich auch unsere
Aufgabe das wollen wir auch tun also wir
wollen uns da nicht wegducken sondern
wir wollen ganz klar auch auch auf die
Missstände dann dementsprechend wenn es
passiert auch dann aufmerksam machen ich
glaube wir haben vor Ort dann
normalerweise nummernhebel und deswegen
ist glaube ich ganz klar
das natürlich von uns auch so oder dafür
steht der DFB dafür steht die Mannschaft
ich glaube das haben schon sich einige
Spieler gemeldet und von daher glaube
ich ist immer da auf dem ganz guten Weg
ich glaube wie ich das ist enorm wichtig
ist dass diese 26 Spieler natürlich die
Chance haben sich auf das zu
konzentrieren für das was wir alle dort
sind nämlich auch auf den Sport
möglichst erfolgreich da auf Fußball zu
spielen und deswegen freuen wir uns alle
auf diese 26 Spieler
und die sollen jetzt auch im Mittelpunkt
stehen und wir starten mit den Torhütern
hier sind die drei die ihr nominiert
habt
[Musik]
ja es war auch bei uns ein großes Thema
ich glaube im Vorfeld waren viele auch
schon informiert dass wir uns Gedanken
gemacht haben im vierten Torwart
mitzunehmen wir haben uns dafür
entschieden weil es auch einfach einen
letzten Turnieren immer so war dass wir
drei mitgenommen haben müssen auch
andere Nationen die drei Torhüter dabei
haben und keinen vierten nominiert haben
und deswegen haben wir uns auch
entschieden dann im Team dass wir uns
auf diese drei ich denke das kann jeder
auch nachvollziehen dass diese drei dann
letztendlich für uns auf dieser Position
auch dass wir die mitnehmen zur
Weltmeisterschaft
dann kommen wir zur Abwehr das ist die
Defensive
[Musik]
ja ich denke
bin verwundert vielleicht für viele das
Lukas Klostermann dabei so weil ich kann
einfach dazu sagen wir sind engen
Austausch immer gewesen mit Lukas Walber
ihn einfach auch auf der Position Häuser
mal das Rechtsverteidigers
sehen aber er hat im Juni wirklich in
der nations League in den nations League
spielen hervorragende
verformt und deswegen haben wir ihn
wirklich eng auch begleitet ich habe
auch mit Marco Rose eng Austausch gehabt
der hat gesagt der ist absolut fit er
war gestern das erste Mal dann im Kader
denke dass am Wochenende vielleicht auch
einen Einsatz hat also vorbei ihm ist es
einfach so dass wir im Verlauf des
Turniers einfach bei ihm auch glauben
dass er dass er dann uns sehr sehr gut
weiterhelfen kann ansonsten ähm ist auch
so dass wir uns freuen dass das arme bei
der ja auch kurz verletzt war
Schulterverletzung hatte bei ihm alles
okay ist alles fit der hat jetzt gestern
ausgesetzt aber ansonsten hat das Spiel
zuvor gemacht es wird am Wochenende noch
mal spielen und von daher
ja sind wir recht zufrieden mit
mit der Auswahl die wir haben wir wenn
man so guckt von der Anzahl 9 Spieler
für die Abwehr nominiert und wir haben
da wirklich auch genügend Spieler die
auf mehreren Positionen spielen können
die uns eine gewisse Variabilität auch
geben und deswegen sind wir da auch sehr
sehr happy
und diese Spieler habt ihr für
Mittelfeld und Angriff nominiert
[Musik]
ja
wir haben zwei Spieler die neu im Kader
sind erstmal dabei erstmal nominiert
wurden Menü coco und mit Niklas Füllkrug
wir freuen uns auf die beiden weil Sie
uns einfach nach den zwei Ausfällen die
wir hatten mit Timo Werner und Lukas
Mescher einfach auch normal das
Besondere geben
Mario Götze ist mit dabei seit langer
Zeit ich glaube zwei 17 war das letzte
Mal dabei und kann nur sagen dass Mario
sich total freut dass er dabei ist und
wir freuen uns auf ihn von daher glaube
ich auch da gibt uns so dieser Kader
oder diese Nominierung wirklich viele
Möglichkeiten die wir die uns in unserem
Spiel und natürlich vielleicht ist ein
oder andere an eine Überraschung geben
kann und deswegen ja auch da wo ich
sagen wenn ich ein Kader so anschaue mir
glaube ich schon sehr sehr froh aber das
wäre so eine Qualität auch im Kader
das sind die 26 Spieler die in Katar
Weltmeister werden möchten das ist ja
bisher schon vier deutschen Mannschaften
gelungen und einige dieser Weltmeister
möchten euch noch ihre besondere
Unterstützung mit nach Katar geben
ja liebe Nationalspieler liebes
Trainerteam liebes Team hinter dem Team
Digitalkabel ist was besonderes es gibt
zu den Startschuss für eine WM die ist
jetzt da und die Tage sind wenige bis es
losgeht in Katar ich wünsche euch von
Herzen viel Energie eine super
Kameradschaft auf große große
Lebensfähigkeit weil die braucht zum
dort etwas zu reißen aber wenn er das
macht ihr seid alle geniale Fußballer
dann habt ihr die Chance Weltmeister zu
werden und diese Chance Weltmeister zu
werden die kommen nicht alle Tage
ganz besonderes das Land zu vertreten
einige von euch haben sie schon
miterleben dürfen ich durfte drei
Weltmeisterschaften miterleben und äh
das war was ganz besonderes ich würde
gern noch mal die Zeituhr zurückdrehen
allein die Leidenschaft der Zusammenhalt
die Emotion die dieses Team geprägt hat
das war der Schlüssel zum Erfolg von
2014 werden extrem viel Statik Charakter
viele Persönlichkeiten viele Alphatiere
aber trotzdem haben es irgendwann
geschafft
die Egos beiseite zu lassen während des
Turniers und dann ganz klar den Weg nach
vorne dass wir die Weltmeisterschaft
gewinnen können schwierig geschafft
haben 1990 war von dem vom allerersten
Tage an eine unglaublich tolle Harmonie
in unserer Truppe nicht nur bei den
ersten Hälfte gespielt haben sondern der
komplette Karte damals ja nur 22 ihr
seid mittlerweile 26 Spieler ihr wisst
schon
Weihnachtszeit die Sterne Zeit also nach
Binz auf der Bitte den fünften Stern mit
nach Deutschland das wichtigste wird
sein
eine gewisse Harmonie und großer
Teamgeist und da glaube ich dann könnte
eure Ziele erreichen ja haben sie ich
weiß du bist schon hungrig auf deine
Aufgabe die jetzt bei der WM vor dir
liegt ich habe das auch etliche Male
miterlebt und dementsprechend weiß ich
je enger es wird zum Beginn ist es umso
erfreulicher dass man gute Leute um sich
hat die einen beruhigen die einen aber
auch durch
tiefe Täler helfen und dementsprechend
bleib du dir deiner Linie treu und da
wünsche ich euch liebes Team dir liebe
Hansi mit deinem stuff alles alles Liebe
ich ja drücke die Daumen werde als
Experte mit dabei sein ich hoffe dass
ihr diesen Erfolg von 2014 wiederholen
könnt
ich habe es Hansi wie du siehst habe ich
heute extra noch mal den ganz alten
Trainingsanzug vom Helmut Schön von 1974
aus meinem Kleiderschrank
hervorgekramt in der Hoffnung dass er
uns beim kommende Turnier wirklich auch
alles Glück bringen dass wir benötigen
denkt noch mal daran was uns 2014 stark
gemacht hat als wir den Pokal gewonnen
haben wir waren in super Team wir haben
jede Minute daran geglaubt dass wir das
Ding gewinnen können und wir haben uns
nie egal was passiert ist aus der Ruhe
bringen lassen diese Qualität dieser
Souveränität die hast Du und Du wirst
das Team super anführen mit deinen
Trainern mit dem gesamten Staat und ich
drücke euch alle Daumen damit wir
erfolgreich sind ich wünsche euch alles
alles Gute
das sind natürlich sehr sehr persönliche
Wünsche an euch auch als Team was aber
glaube ich alle betont haben ist die
Fähigkeit ein Team zu sein die Egos
zurückzustellen ist das auch was was für
euch besonders wichtig ist ist für jede
Mann wichtig die die Erfolg haben will
und ich eigentlich kann man die den Film
einfach eine Mannschaft zeigen und dann
hat man alles drin was man braucht und
ja von hat er gesehen viel Erfahrung
sehr erfolgreiche Fußballer und Trainer
also von daher glaube ich ist alles drin
was man braucht oder können wir uns
einfach vieles rausnehmen deswegen danke
noch mal für für die guten Wünsche wir
geben es der Mannschaft zu weiter und
wir hoffen es war einfach einen guten
guter Stadt für eine erfolgreiche WM
das hoffen wir und freuen uns auf eure
und ihre Fragen wir würden im Raum
starten und dann in die digitale Welt
gehen
so na gut dann
Sonja Paul bitte
ja herrlich erstmal ja schönes Aufgebot
sag ich einfach mal
vor allen Dingen aus Frankfurter sich
freuen wir uns natürlich sage ich jetzt
auch aus hessischer Sicht Mario Götze
ist mit dabei Kevin trappist dabei sie
haben ja gerade schon ein bisschen
erwähnt war dass Mario sich selber
gefreut hat was hat denn schließlich und
endlich den Ausschlag gegeben was der
Erfolg von Eintracht Frankfurt als
Ganzes oder Mario der sich einfach
wunderbar auch in die Bundesliga an das
ganze Level auch wieder eingearbeitet
hat
ja das ist letztendlich dass das zweite
ist steht bei uns natürlich im Fokus
noch letztendlich was wie performte ja
und was kann er für uns natürlich als
Mannschaft auch geben und ich glaube wir
alle wissen dass das Mario einfach auch
ein genialer Fußballer ist der will ich
auch
Gedankenblitze hat die ja die einfach
intuitiv macht und wenn man sieht so die
letzten Spiele egal letzten Spiel lieber
beobachtet haben war es schon auf dem
ganz ganz hohen Niveau ich glaube die
die ersten Spieler in der Saison auch
die Belastung mit mit international alle
drei vier Tage und das hat ihn hat ihn
schon diese mal so ein bisschen ich sage
einfach mal so an die Grenze gebracht
und und
aber jetzt ist er man sieht sein jedem
Spieler ist es topfit er kann 90 Minuten
auch dreimal die Woche gehen und das ist
natürlich schon eine gute Voraussetzung
und dann ist es einfach auch ein
genialer Fußballer und ein toller Mensch
dann Frank Hellmann bitte
er fliegt hier da genau ich würde noch
mal bei den beiden Stürmer nachfragen wo
coco und Füllkrug sind ja
unterschiedliche Spielertypen der eine
jung und klein der andere eher groß ein
bisschen älter war auch der einzige der
noch ein vereins-trikot getragen hat
weil er noch nie U21 oder
A-Nationalmannschaft gespielt hat was
sind die Planspiele mit ihnen kann man
sagen so sie Edeljoker für die wenn dann
Strategie oder möglicherweise auch mehr
mario hat auch Mario Götz hat auch das
Vereins Trikot getragen glaube ich
meine es ist so dass das beide natürlich
eine gute Entwicklung gemacht haben
Niklas hat zehn Tore er hat so welchen
Moment weil es hat Momentum so auf
seiner Seite er macht es sehr gut ich
habe auch damit Olive Werner auch lange
gesprochen auch die Art und Weise wie er
sich in ins Team mit einbringt also es
war alles sehr sehr positiv und man
sieht natürlich auch an den Toren aber
die er macht dass er daran auch arbeitet
und das ist so auch also man das
Feedback was ich von Ole bekommen habe
dass er mich einer ist der ständig
versucht sich zu verbessern und dass er
einer ist der der Mannschaft immer so
den ja das ist Vertrauen schenkt dass
das immer noch was geht und wenn man
wenn man so die Spiele von von Bremen
auch in der Vergangenheit zur mal
betrachtet ist schon so dass in den
letzten Minuten teilweise immer mal
wieder was umgebogen wurde dass sie
zurückgekommen sind und und das sagt er
halt natürlich schon ist er einer der
der
Mannschaft dieses Vertrauen dieses
Selbstverständnis auch gibt und darüber
hinaus ist auch einer der Glaube sich
mit dieser Rolle egal wie sie auch
letztendlich aussieht
auch gut identifizieren kann weil er
happy ist froh ist und es muss ja auch
noch mal sagen jeder einzelne Spieler
glaube ich freut sich so dass er dabei
ist freut sich auf diese WM diese WM zu
spielen Fußball spielen zu können mit
den Besten der Besten messen zu können
und das ist auch bei nikl Durchfall und
yusufer macht einfach eine gute
Entwicklung ergibt natürlich auch eine
Mannschaft sehr viel er ist schnell er
ist quirliger hat einen guten Abschluss
im März am Wochenende auch gesehen hat
von daher
freuen wir uns auf ihn weil es einfach
auch ist neue Spieler noch mal
kennenzulernen und deswegen freuen wir
uns natürlich auf beide
da machen wir direkt daneben mit Arne
Richter weiter
hallo sie hatten gesagt dass sie mit
Mats Hummels eine klare Absprache hatten
Lauf letzten Wochen was hatte den
Ausschlag gegeben dass sie ihn jetzt
nicht brauchen bei der WM und wenn man
auf den Kader guckt sind zwei Teenager
dabei 220-jährige ist das auch eine
klare Ansage Richtung Zukunft auf die
Turniere die nach Katana kommen werden
erstmal ist es wichtig dass man dass man
eine gute WM eine erfolgreiche WM
spielen alles andere ist ist dann eher
der zweite Schritt trotzdem ist es
natürlich auch so haben wir uns im
Trainerteam dass ich auch Gedanken
gemacht
wenn man jemanden Kader zusammenstellen
und und so eine Erfahrung der WM
Erfahrung zu haben ist natürlich auch
für für die Zukunft richtig gut wertvoll
und ja ich es ist es ist so ist nicht
nur bei matso und tut natürlich
wahnsinnig leid so mit Timo Werner dass
er ausfällt das habe ich schon
letztendlich auch auch gesagt dass es
für uns ein wichtiger Spieler ist der
bei uns immer wirklich gut verformt hat
auch getroffen hat eine gute Quote hat
dann ist ja jetzt beim Spielen ich
glaube am Dienstag was Lukas mecher
ausgefallen
kommen jetzt noch mal bevor ich zu Matz
komme einfach nochmal auch auf dem Marco
Reus ja ich glaube ich habe schon oft
gesagt wie sehr ich ihn Schätze als
Fußballer ist einfach
mit seiner Gabe die er hat gerade im
letzten Drittel tut da jedermannschaft
gut und er wird uns fehlen es war
einfach auch so er hat alles probiert er
hat alles probiert
ja wirklich noch mal
auf den WM-Zug aufzuspringen aber so
eine Verletzung die hat einfach auch
braucht seine Zeit und deswegen mussten
wir uns halt einfach auch entscheiden
dann
ja irgendwann ob man das Risiko eingehen
oder nicht und und weil es halt auch
nicht ganz klar war wann er dazu stoßen
kann das ist bei anderen anders ja und
deswegen haben wir uns dann entschieden
und habe es mit Marco auch so besprochen
und das tut ja uns einfach weh weil man
so eine Qualität einfach auch gut
gebrauchen können und bei Max was einen
Versuch so dass mir viele Spiele von ihm
angeguckt haben von Dortmund angeguckt
haben und Mats natürlich schon auch in
dieser
man muss einfach sagen er hat
er hat eine hervorragende Form er ist
topfit und hat jetzt Dortmund auch
vieles gegeben denkt für ihn für
Dortmund welchen sehr sehr wertvoller
Spieler und wir haben uns halt
entschieden im Trainerteam weil wir
natürlich auch
vielleicht noch ein bisschen die Zukunft
im Blick haben das war gesagt haben okay
wir haben es für ein jüngeren Spieler
entschieden nicht gegen mats und wir
haben uns für die Mannschaft entschieden
ähm Mats kann glaube jeder Mannschaft
gut tun und trotzdem war das für uns
einfach auch den Blick dann eher so in
die Zukunft
dann bleiben wir in der Reihe Sebastian
Wessling für die Funke Medien
so jetzt habe ich die Technik auch raus
ich würde noch einmal nachbohren wollen
bei Mats Hummels sie haben ja auch
gesagt wichtig ist jetzt ein gutes
Turnier zu spielen können wir auf die
sportlichen Beweggründe eingehen warum
die Entscheidung jetzt gegen ihn
ausgefallen ist
wir haben
wenn ich jetzt mal unsere vier
Innenverteidiger mit Niklas süle mit
Matze Kinder mit mit Antonio Rüdiger und
Nico stotterbeck nehmen es sind vier
vier Innenverteidiger die ich schon ohne
enorme Qualität haben wir froh sind dass
wir dass wir diese diese Spieler bei uns
sind im Kader haben und dann wenn man
dann noch Tilo Kehre dazu nimmt oder
auch arme Bella haben wir auf dieser
Position natürlich schon auch genügend
Qualitäten und genügend Spieler und von
daher glaube kann man dann schon dann
auch verstehen wenn man sagt okay wir
nehmen jetzt hat einen jüngeren Spieler
mit
wir gehen einen Platz nach rechts Manuel
buhnke
wir haben gerade über die
Innenverteidiger kurz gesprochen Niklas
süle haben sie da genannt ist er für sie
auch in Aktion als Rechtsverteidiger sie
haben ihn das in München schon spielen
lassen in Dortmund macht das auch
aktuell oder ist er ihnen wirklich im
Zentrum gesetzt
ich glaube da haben wir noch ein
bisschen Luft und ist das schöne ist ja
dann auch wenn man wenn man so die
Updates sieht dass wir wirklich einige
Spieler haben die auf verschiedenen
Positionen spielen können und wir
natürlich auch je nach nach Matchplan
dann auch reagieren können und von daher
ist es schön natürlich dass er jetzt bei
Dortmund auch auf der Rechtsverteidigung
Position spielt gibt uns natürlich auch
eine Option mehr und aber wie es alles
aussieht wie man spielen dass das wenn
man dann von Spiel zu spielen
entscheiden
dann Philipp seidorf bitte
Hansi wie lange beobachtest du Niklas
Füllkrug schon wie lange hast du ihn auf
der Liste und
war das womöglich im Sommer schon mal
ein Gedanken wert auf ihn zu achten und
wie beurteilst du seine Einsatzchancen
beim Turnier
also erstmal ist es ist es wichtig dass
er dass wir ihn mal richtig kennenlernen
ähm
beobachten ist vielleicht man das erste
Mal als mir aufgefallen ist so das war
damals auch mit mit Horst Ruprecht 2016
wo es wo es darum ging Spieler für für
Olympia auch zu nominieren und da ist er
dann aber gewechselt nach Hannover meine
ich mich zu erinnern und dann war klare
Absprache dass Spieler die neu beim
Verein sind nicht nicht mitgenommen
werden deswegen wäre damals vielleicht
schon dabei gewesen
ja er hat ich finde ich habe ihn
mehrmals gesehen unter anderem in
Hoffenheim und die Art und Weise wir
Fußball spielt so als sehr bald sicher
wenn man natürlich seine Tore aussieht
ist das was ich vorhin gesagt habe
einfach auch einen guten Abschluss mit
beiden Beinen und natürlich auch das
eine Tor was jetzt gemacht hat so als
kopffall teurer natürlich schon auch ein
Element was was uns dann ganz vorne auch
schon gut tut und nochmal wie
inwieweit dass das an jedem Spieler
selbst neu wie weit dass er dann in
unserer in unseren Überlegungen dann für
ein Spieltag dann auch vorkommt liegt an
jedem Spieler selbst
dann Heiko Ostendorf
sie haben gerade die Verletzten oder die
Ausfälle auch schon angesprochen können
Sie uns noch mal so ein bisschen
Einblick geben was das Szenario ist für
den Fall dass noch weitere Spiele
ausfallen was natürlich keiner hofft
aber es ist ja nun mal noch ein
Bundesliga Spieltag auch wenn sie sich
das glaube ich anders gewünscht hätten
was also gibt es dann eine Liste mit
Spielern die die quasi jeweils als
Backup fungieren oder wie darf man sich
das vorstellen und bis wann ist
eigentlich da genau was möglich weil
gestern gab es noch mal das Gerücht dass
die FIFA noch mal die die Frist
verlängert hat bis zum 14
also nach meinen Informationen ist es so
dass dass wir bis 24 Stunden vom ersten
Spieltag wenn was passiert wenn einer
sich verletzt natürlich dann auch wird
ein FIFA Arzt drauf schauen dann auch
noch mal nachnominieren können also
deswegen ist einfach so ich hoffe nicht
dass jetzt erwarten dass ich jetzt in
eine Liste die dann nachnominiert werden
eines machen wir nicht klar ist es bei
uns natürlich auch im in unsere Gedanken
drin unsere Überlegungen aber
so dass bis wie 24 Stunden vom ersten
Spieltag da muss die Liste
abgegeben werden und bis dahin können
wir wenn sie was wenn was passiert auch
auch noch mal austauschen
hallo Herr Flick er fliegt sie waren
sicherlich auch eng im Austausch mit
Thomas Müller wie können sie für ihn mit
ihm aktuell planen schon für auch für
die Vorbereitung und würden sie noch mal
sagen wie wichtig ist ihnen dieser kurze
Aufenthalt in im Oman auch mit dem
Testspiel und auch das Zusammensein dort
das erinnert ja so ein bisschen an das
was sie vor dem finaltunnel mit Bayern
München Lissabon gemacht haben
ja Thomas so immer auch engem Austausch
und ist auch so dass er
dass er in guten Aufbau hat bin
überzeugt davon dass er noch nie so gut
vorbereitet war für eine WM einfach weil
er weil er halt viele
ja viele Läufer hat und ich glaube da
aber ganz guten Fitness auch ankommt
wir rechnen natürlich jeden hoffen
natürlich dass er im ersten Spiel jetzt
ein Freundschaftsspiel gegen Roman dass
wir ihn da einsetzen können das ist so
unser Ziel um einfach auch dann zum
nächsten Schritt zu gehen
ansonsten ist es Oman natürlich schon
auch erstmal wichtig dass wir ist einmal
von wenn Alternative wäre gewesen
bleiben in Deutschland das heißt jetzt
gerade aktuell ja scheint glaube ich die
Sonne aber
wir wissen alle dass im November das
Wetter nicht immer ganz so mitspielt
deswegen glaube ich ist auch mal vorher
ein bisschen vor Ort zu sein und die
Temperaturen auch anzunehmen und die
Tageszeiten auch anzunehmen und war uns
schon wichtig und dann das Spiel dann
gegen Oman war auch gut dass wir das
dann vor Ort machen konnten
und dann werden wir relativ schnell die
Sommer nach dem nach dem Fronter Spiel
gegen Oman dann auch Richtung Qatar
fahren oder fliegen weil es einfach für
uns so wichtig ist vor Ort dann noch
einmal ja runter zu fahren weil alle
Spieler haben oder viele Spieler haben
wirklich viele Minuten in den Beinen und
da geht es einfach darum dass wir
natürlich gerade die ersten Tage die
ersten Tage schauen okay wer braucht
eventuell eine kleine Pause oder wir
brauchen eine Regeneration und wer
braucht die Spiele und für uns
letztendlich beginnt es ist natürlich
diesmal komplett anders als das in den
Turnieren zuvor war
ist haben wir letztendlich für uns viel
Match Match die -4 beginnt letztendlich
der Fokus auf auf Japan und alles andere
ist jetzt eher dazu da dass wir uns ein
bisschen akklimatisieren und aber
natürlich auch uns holen und Körner
wieder
auffüllen und dann vier Tage vor dem
ersten Spiel in das erste Training
reingehen
dann hier ganz vorne Oliver
im September haben wir hier
zusammengesessen und da war das Thema
der kriselnde bayernblock ich denke mal
die Entwicklung freut sie wie wichtig
ist dass der Block wieder zu dieser
Stärke gefunden hat und haben Sie sich
schon bei Julian nagelsmann bedankt
ich habe bei Julian schon ich habe eine
WhatsApp geschrieben hat gesagt ich
freue mich echt dass ihr so gut performt
hatte geschrieben er freut sich auch
also von daher glaube ich immer da und
so einig das ist einfach wichtig und
schön zu sehen gibt uns natürlich auch
auch
ein gewisses Vertrauen auch aber
trotzdem ist es natürlich sind
ein Teil der Spieler die die
einer guten Form sind aber wir brauchen
letztendlich alle die dieses ja dieses
Turnier annehmen welche in jedem
Training einfach auch zeigen was für
eine qualitätsjahren zeigen warum das
sie mit dabei sind das ist einfach
wichtig dass wir ein absoluten Fokus im
Training haben und nur durch das was wir
wenn man gut trainieren wenn man da
absolut fokussiert sind können wir auch
ein gutes Turnier spielen
dann Patrick Berger
hier war das halli Hallo
Antonio Rüdiger ist bei ihnen ein klarer
Abwehr Boss jetzt ist zur Zeit so dass
er eine Hüftverletzung hat in Spanien
hat man sogar überlegt ist er dann am
Ende wirklich dabei muss man sich da
Sorgen machen mit Blick auf das erste
Spiel wie es da die Absprache und
vielleicht noch ein Satz zu Flo wird der
ebenfalls verletzt ist jetzt nicht
unbedingt überraschend dass er da nicht
auftaucht aber gab es da vielleicht
sogar Gedankengänge auch mit zwei 24 ihn
mitzunehmen
ja also toni ist ist so unser Abwehrchef
und wir freuen uns natürlich dass er
dass er dabei ist und ich sehe da gab da
überhaupt keine Bedenken im Gegenteil er
ist ich glaube das so man hat ihn
rausgenommen und wir sind da im
Austausch auch mit mit
Abteilung von real also da ich glaube
die letzten die letzten Woche oder zehn
Tage war ich mit unserem Doc Jochen
Hahne ständig im Austausch ich weiß
nicht wie viele Telefonate wir geführt
haben hätten eigentlich einen
Standleitung auch gebraucht aber es ist
gut er ist da auch wie ich voll
integriert und und hält mich immer auf
dem Laufenden also von daher gibt es
aktuell den Kader den immer nominiert
haben aber ich keine Fragezeichen noch
keine Bedenken die wir haben und bei Flo
das war so ein Spieler mit seiner
Qualität gerne auch natürlich dabei
gehabt hätten brauche jetzt hier nicht
zu erwähnen ich glaube das weiß jeder
aber natürlich ist eine auch so dass
eine schwere Verletzung hatte dass er
lange draußen war er ist jetzt gerade
dabei dass er im Mannschaftstraining
mitmacht und
und ich glaube es wichtigste ist
entscheidend ist für ihn dass er wieder
gut gesund wie ich auf dem Platz kommt
dass er die Spiele im wenn es dann
beginnt im Januar da wieder voll dabei
ist und absoluter Fokus dann auf ja auf
die nächsten die nächsten Aufgaben die
er mit Leverkusen hat aber vielleicht
auch damit uns hat und da deswegen
glaube ich ist es der richtige Weg dass
er ganz konzentriert auch an seiner
Spielfähigkeit wieder trainiert
hier in der Mitte haben Scherzer
hallo Herr Frick ich habe eine Frage was
Mario Götze betrifft können Sie etwas
über die Kommunikation mit ihm erzählt
seit wann sie mit ihm im Gespräch waren
und wie sie im Gespräch waren danke
also meine sind natürlich immer Dinge
die man Trainer und Spieler hat und die
über die man nicht gerne redet ne aber
es ist schon so dass wir dass wir das
länger an Kontakt haben und
wir haben auch im Vorfeld immer wieder
Kontakt gehabt auch meiner Zeit als ich
bei Bayern Trainer war
immer wieder mit Mario Kontakt gehabt
und alle von daher sie Kommunikation
schon etwas länger
direkt daneben Christian Kamm
könnten Sie vielleicht noch ein bisschen
ausführen wie sie inhaltlich
fußballerisch auf den Ausfall von Timo
Werner reagieren wollen also sehr doch
jemand der mir sehr eigene Qualität mit
seinem Tempo mitbringt sie haben öfter
erzählt wie sehr das Spiel dann doch auf
ihn zugeschnitten ist bedeutet es ein
größeren strukturellen Umbau also ist
das ein größeres eine größere
Herausforderung jetzt auch das zu
kompensieren und kommen dann für diese
Rolle auch vielleicht Leute in Frage die
es zuletzt nicht so gespielt haben sehr
knabbrige können wir in den Sinn der das
ja immer mal gespielt hat aber zuletzt
wieder bei den Bayern noch noch bei
Ihnen
das sind schon auch Gedanken die wir
haben also wir haben den Kader natürlich
schon so wenn man
aber wir haben viele Spieler im
Offensivbereich die auf mehreren
Positionen spielen können und
unser unsere Idee vom Fußball ist schon
dass man Gegner unter Druck setzen
wollen deswegen brauchen wir vorne
natürlich ein Spieler der gut anlaufen
kann der gut mitmachen kann der taktisch
gut
ja
integriert ist auch in das ganze in das
ganze die ganze Idee und vor allen
Dingen der auch bereit ist diese Wege zu
gehen gegen den Ball und glaube mit Ball
aber wie viele Optionen die die wir ja
die wir uns da mit dem Kader auch offen
gelassen haben deswegen kann es mehrere
mehrere Spieler letztendlich können das
auch ausfüllen
dann hätten wir hier im Raum noch Sven
westerschulze und danach Arne Steinberg
und dann gehen wir ins digitale
EMI hat unter ihnen debitiert war jetzt
aber zuletzt
Entschuldigung
der Nationalmannschaft war jetzt zuletzt
aber über ein Jahr nicht mehr dabei hat
es bei Borussia Dortmund seit seinem
Wechsel noch nicht ganz an die starken
Leistung anknüpfen können die man in
Salzburg von ihm gesehen hat was waren
die Gründe was hat Ausschlag dafür
gegeben dass die Karim jetzt doch
vielleicht ein Stück überraschend
nominiert haben
überraschend sein wir sehen halt im
Karim schon dass er eine herausragende
Waffe hat also ich bin da auch
bei ihnen man die
die Leistung die jetzt in Dortmund
gebracht hat ich glaube Dortmund hat sie
mehr versprochen er hat sich auch mehr
versprochen trotzdem ist es ins Spieler
der der in dem Spiel
einfach eine Option hat so durch seine
Schnelligkeit Autos seinen guten
Abschluss eine Mannschaft oder auch
vorbereiten letzten Pass der eine
Mannschaft was geben kann ja eine von
den verschiedenen Situationen ich denke
da an das Spiel gegen Bayern München als
als Dortmund hin gelegen ist sondern er
kommt rein und hat er schon einfach nur
mal gewirbelt und neu Impulse gesetzt
der Mannschaft einfach auch normal noch
mal zurückgebracht ins Spiel das sind so
Dinge die die wir natürlich auch
überlegen aber klar ist natürlich auch
dass wir von ihm einfach auch mehr
erwarten und und dass wir ihn jetzt auch
in denen in der kurzen Zeit einfach auch
begleiten damit der genau diese Dinge
besser macht die wir von ihm erwarten
und Anne Steinberg da vorne
[Musik]
angeklungen sie hatten erwähnt viele
Spieler haben viele Spiele schon in den
beiden haben viel Spiele gemacht und
einige ihrer Kollegen in den Vereinen
haben sich auch beschwert über den
vollen Wettkampfkalender pep Guardiola
hat vor einigen Tagen gesagt die WM sei
verrückt weil die Spieler keine Pausen
hätten zu Regeneration jetzt auch im
Vorfeld wie schätzen Sie diese
Problematik ein
ja ich meine da kann ich da kann ich
schon mitgehen ja auch wenn wenn so eine
Weltmeisterschaft natürlich für ein
Ja Nationaltrainer einfach die die
Möglichkeit ist da noch ein Turnier
teilzunehmen ist es schon so dass man
letztendlich die Gesamtbelastung der
Spieler auch im Auge haben muss und das
kann ich noch mehr werden und ich finde
das muss man muss man wirklich auch da
muss man auch Sorge tragen ich finde und
da ist es halt bei uns ein bisschen
anders in Deutschland als als jetzt in
England findet natürlich auch super dass
das nach dem Turnier einfach wie eine
Pause haben die Spieler in der Pause
haben und von daher muss man einfach
Komplimente auch an die DFL dass sie
dass sie letztendlich da wie ich auch
drauf schaut dass die Spieler zumindest
mal etwas Erholung haben deswegen sind
wir glaube ich auf dem guten Weg aber
ich kann natürlich absolut verstehen
wenn pep Guardiola das anmahnt aber ich
glaube einfach wir müssen wir müssen
gucken dass wir das Rad nicht überdrehen
sondern dass wir dass wir auch nach
anderen Spielern einfach gucken dass sie
nicht zu sehr sondern die Mühle geraten
ich würde noch eine Frage im Raum
anschließen
möchten vorstellen
ja
hallo Herr
pflegerpanische Journalist und wurde man
zwei Fragen und zwar der erste einzige
japanische Kader wurde schon ganz
bekannter gegeben oder welche Eindruck
haben sind schon und zweite Frage haben
sie schon im Kopf irgendwie der
Ausstellung zur Bürgermeisterschaft
geben wenn Sie wollen
ich schätze in japanischen Fußball sehr
meines spielen viele viele auch bei uns
in Deutschland und einfach die Qualität
die Sie haben Fußball sehr starke
Mannschaft und
ja von daher äußert für uns eine große
Aufgabe gerade im ersten Spiel und wir
spielen ich glaube da haben wir noch ein
bisschen Zeit und da wird es noch vieles
vieles passieren deswegen wenn sie mich
da vielleicht
Tag in der Abschluss PK vom Spiel Fragen
kann ich vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
sagen als jetzt aber so viel weiß jetzt
auch nicht
dann gehen wir ins digitale und starten
mit Christian Falk
so weit also die Pressekonferenz mit
Hansi fliegt Thomas gulski ist nach wie
vor bei mir und wir ordnen das ganze
jetzt mal ein bisschen ein vielleicht
noch mal ganz kurz zusammengefasst die
Statements des Bundestrainers wer kann
der Mannschaft helfen das war der
Leitgedanke wer kann in bestimmten
Situationen eventuell dann der
Matchwinner sein natürlich auch mal
wichtig bei so einem Turnier aber man
hat auch gesagt man will apropos Turnier
in Katar auch auf Missstände aufmerksam
machen dass vielleicht also auch noch
mal zum ausser sportlichen Teil also mit
Götze mitfühlkrug mit mukoko ohne Reus
ohne Hummels ohne Würz um nur ein paar
Namen schon mal zu nennen wir gucken
Thomas jetzt noch mal gemeinsam auf die
einzelnen Mannschaftsteile wollen wir
vielleicht gerade mal mit dem Tor
anfangen ich denke da sind keine großen
Überraschungen erwartet worden und die
gab es dann auch in der Tat nicht tun
Überraschung wäre gewesen wenn es nicht
die drei gewesen wären und auch ein
vierter wäre die Möglichkeit hat ja
bestanden wer sicherlich eine
Überraschung zumindest für mich gewesen
klar Manuel Neuer also bei Bayern
irgendwie und Hierarchie ist klar ja die
Nummer 1 neuer seit unseren gesetzt aber
auch testing bei Barcelona und Trapp
natürlich auch bei Frankfurt mit einer
starken Saison insbesondere natürlich
auch in der letzten tollen Saison die
anderen beiden würden wahrscheinlich bei
ich weiß nicht 32 der anderen 33 WM
Teilnehmer die Nummer eins sein was die
Torhüter dafür hatte Deutschland selten
ein Problem da waren eigentlich immer
sehr gute Vertreter und man hatte
eigentlich immer die Qual der Wahl wir
wollen unsere fachkundige Runde hier
noch ein bisschen erweitern wir sprechen
nämlich außerdem noch mit Felix casalino
er ist unter anderem Stürmer in der
Regionalliga West bei der SG
Wattenscheid 09 und außerdem und das ist
auch nicht unwichtig Mitglied des
youtube-kanals freekickers mit knapp 9
Millionen Abonnenten einer der
erfolgreichsten Youtube Kanäle
Deutschlands hallo und herzlich
Willkommen Felix casalino hi
Runde ich freue mich danke schön
vielleicht auch kurz deine Einschätzung
noch zur Torwartposition wir haben jetzt
gerade schon besprochen keine
Überraschung nehme ich an auch bei Dir
ja ich kann euch da voll recht geben und
zustimmen also wenn die drei nicht
nominiert gewesen wären wäre es eine
große Überraschung gewesen in der Tat
gut dann Angel wir uns doch einfach mal
zur nächsten Position dann gucken wir
doch direkt auf die Abwehr da gab es
vielleicht schon die ein oder andere
offene Frage die dann heute eben auch
beantwortet ist gucken wir darauf Thomas
deine Einschätzung wenn wir uns die
Namen anschauen also da war ja der
Knackpunkt ab Mats Hummels dabei sein
wird oder nicht er ist jetzt nicht dabei
mit den nachvollziehbaren Argumenten des
Bundestrainers der sagt er hat sich für
die Zukunft entschieden der
Bundestrainer hat sich schon vor einiger
Zeit entschieden dass Antonio Rüdiger
der neue Abwehrchef ist die Nummer eins
neben ihm soll süle sein und die Backups
mit Schlotterbeck und
in dem Fall jetzt wenn du noch mal
draufschaust genau also gibt es ja
einige die da jetzt und die Backups sind
auch nicht ohne ja genau
Günther ist vielleicht für den ein oder
anderen überraschend dass er dabei ist
dafür ist großes nicht dabei der hat
auch keine große Rolle gespielt bei
Inter Mailand in dieser Zeit
die Entscheidung gegen gegen Hummels
hätte auch hat auch
mannschaftsinterne Gründe glaube ich
weil ein Charakterkopf wie Hummels
bringt natürlich auch Strukturen
durcheinander und die Öffentlichkeit
hätte natürlich sehr auf Matz geschaut
oder dabei gewesen natürlich dann eben
auch Nachfragen seitens der Presse
gerade und da hatte auch der
Bundestrainer gesagt ja es ist nicht
gegen Mats die Entscheidung gefallen wie
man das dann immer sagt es ging um das
für bei den jüngeren Spielern also dass
man da eben dann auch auf die Zukunft
setzt auch im Hinblick dann auf die
Turniere die dann kommen vielleicht
Felix auch noch mal deine Einschätzung
zu den Nominierten Abwehrspielern
ja ich finde genau die Position Hummels
und Bella Ketchup ist so dass worüber
man quatschen kann ich glaube alle
anderen Positionen geht man relativ
schnell da Kochen mit auch das ein
Günther dabei ist hat sich verdient ich
weiß nicht ob ein Hummels gerade wenn es
vielleicht in der spätere Phase in der
WM geht auch wichtig werden kann intern
in der Mannschaft von Bella kotschatz
sich vielleicht zurückhält aber auch ein
Hummel Zweck einer Mannschaft Struktur
gibt ich gebe euch aber auch recht und
Hummels kann mit seinem standing auch
für Unruhe sorgen ich finde es sind zwei
Schienen die man fahren kann haben sie
Klick hat sich für die Schiene der das
jüngeren Spielers entschieden wo die
auch sicherlich gut ist und im Hinblick
auf zwei 24 wichtig ist ich weiß noch
nicht ob im Hinblick auf den späteren
Verlauf einer WM einen Hummels auch
nicht uninteressant gewesen wäre ob er
spielt oder nicht sei dahingestellt aber
ich meine auch Team intern auch das was
gar nicht die Außenwelt mitbekommen was
einfach im im dm-lager in Deutschland
stattfindet glaube ich ist Hummels nicht
uninteressant da würde ich gerade
einhaken wollen weil wie das auch über
Youtube hören also mehrere nachfragen wo
ist Hummels ohne Hummels Fragezeichen
also oder mutig auch schreibt uns
Serious Sam die Sache mit Hummels macht
für mich keinen Sinn sagt till da kann
man schwierigste Argumentationen des
Bundestrainer weil Matz hat ja und das
spricht total für ihn sehr offen und
ehrlich gesagt er wird jede Rolle
akzeptieren das inkludiert auch dass er
bis zum Halbfinale auf der Bank
zufrieden wäre und die Frage ist was
passiert wenn Antonio Rüdiger der neue
Abwehrchef ausfällt da könnte man
natürlich auf die Idee kommen das
hummelst dann neue Abwehrchef würde und
mit den anderen beiden von Borussia
Dortmund die spielen das ja auch
zusammen seit Wochen im Verein doch auch
noch ein festes Abwehr pollwerk wäre
weil der bayernblock ist die eine
Geschichte und der Bundestrainer muss
gucken was funktioniert sofort ja über
den bayernblock werden wir gleich noch
sprechen nämlich wenn wir uns vielleicht
jetzt den nächsten Mannschaftsteil schon
anschauen Mittelfeld und dann auch
später der Angriff denn da sind die
Bayern natürlich prominent vertreten
gucken wir gerade noch gemeinsam drauf
zunächst mal das Mittelfeld Julian
Brandt war auch nicht unbedingt zwingend
überrascht ja er hat eine sehr gute
Entwicklung genommen in den letzten
Wochen bei Borussia Dortmund ich meine
identhersage gibt ihnen das Vertrauen
und er gibt es zurück gut jetzt hat er
ein unglücklichen Ballverlust in
Wolfsburg gehabt der der zum 0:2 geführt
hat da ist halt Licht und Schatten bei
ihm oftmals gegeben aber er ist
natürlich einer der in auf vielen
Positionen da einspringen kann also
viele Bayern über die reden wir gleich
noch mal aber zunächst vielleicht auch
noch mal die Personalie oben rechts
Mario Götze das war ja nun auch eine
ganz große Frage nimmt er den wm-held
von 2014 mit Ja oder Nein auch immerhin
schon 30 Jahre alt länger jetzt nicht
gespielt in der Nationalmannschaft er
hat sich für ihn entschieden ja und das
nicht zufällig sondern es ist eine
Würdigung seiner Leistung bei Eintracht
Frankfurt aus meiner Sicht ist die
Spielweise von Eintracht Frankfurt aber
auch ziemlich perfekt auf die Spielweise
von Mario Götze zugeschnitten und
gerade in Bayern Kader hast du natürlich
viele die sowas spielen können wie Mario
Götze der Mannschaft geben kann
andererseits hast du diesen Moment aus
dem Sommer 2014 und er das Tor macht ja
für dieses Tor werden viele viele
Deutsche für immer dankbar sein und er
spielt natürlich großartig derzeit das
ist auch das was Hansi Flick auch noch
mal gesagt hat er sei einfach ein
genialer Fußballer der Mario Götze und
er würde eben auch auf einem sehr hohen
Level und das jetzt schon seit mehreren
Wochen spielen und deswegen das
Vertrauen eben von haben sie Flick ja
dann machen wir doch vielleicht nur
nehmen wir vielleicht doch mal hier
unseren weiteren Experten mit in die
Runde Felix casalino vielleicht auch
noch mal von dir kurz die Einschätzung
zum Mittelfeld
ja ich glaube auch da viele Namen waren
von Anfang an klar das Götze mitkommt
wundert mich erstmal schon also wie
gesagt er spielt gerade eine super
Saison bei Frankfurt ist aber auch
glaube ich gerade jemand der profitiert
davon dass ein Flo wird es nicht
rechtzeitig geschafft hat dass Marco
Reus jetzt doch nicht mitkommt ich
glaube dass da Mario Götze jemand ist
der dann
reinrutscht das heißt aber nicht dass es
nicht berechtigt ist also ich finde
absolut verdient er spielt eine super
Saison hat sich das verdient und ja das
ist ein Reus nicht geschafft hat ein
Witz nicht geschafft hat ist sehr sehr
schade aber ich glaube das Götze davon
auch profitiert ja noch mal ganz kurz du
als Stürmer würdest ja auch sagen wir
mal einen Spieler wie Götze gerne mit
Sicherheit in deiner Mannschaft haben
denn er versorgt ja auch die Spitzen
regelmäßig mit sehr guten zuspielen
einmal das aber ich finde auch letztes
jemand der wirklich auch in den letzten
Jahren sehr Zweikampf stark geworden ist
und viel nach hinten arbeitet ich glaube
das sieht man auch in den Spielen von
Frankfurt jetzt auch in der Champions
League wo geackert wurde wo gekämpft
wurde und wo geht's auch immer jemand
war der vorangegangen ist also da hat er
sich wirklich weiterentwickelt er ist
nicht mehr nur der
Schönwetter Fußballer oder auch der der
mit Hacke Spitze spielt sondern äh der
arbeitet auf dem Platz gewinnt viele
Zweikämpfe also wie gesagt das ist eine
Entscheidung die hat er sich verdient
ich kann sie fliegt da verstehen ja hat
also enorm auch an seiner Fitness
gearbeitet in den vergangenen Jahren
mache ich Wurzel war ja früher immer so
ein bisschen seine Achillesferse aber da
muss man sagen seit seiner Zeit
spätestens in den Niederlanden und jetzt
auch bei Frankfurt gibt er sich da
eigentlich keine böse er ist von der
Optik ein ganz anderer als zu anderen
Zeiten das ist sehr auffällig ja hat
auch offensichtlich hat er auch seine
Krankheit jetzt wirklich überwunden
immer hervorragende laufwerte auch also
macht wirklich spul da auch Kilometer
runter das muss man echt sagen also
alles andere als ein Stand oder schöner
er setzt sich richtig ein so deswegen
eben auch aus unserer Sicht die Berufung
zurecht zumindest jetzt wenn ich meine
Experten hier richtig verstehe kann man
hier mögen muss ich sagen ja auch das so
und dann gucken wir vielleicht noch mal
auf den letzten noch fehlenden
Mannschaftsteil und sprechen dann auch
noch mal um den oder über den Bayern
Blog denn wir haben vom FC Bayern
insgesamt sogar sechs Feldspieler
nebenanuel neuer dem Tor ist also sieben
Spieler insgesamt dabei das ist also
schon eine macht
ich glaube das ist auch ein Faktor auf
den Hansi Flick maßgeblich setzt wie
gesagt er muss gucken was funktioniert
sofort und die Bayern und da sagt er ja
dass er Julian nagelsmann dankbar ist
und ihm schon eine WhatsApp geschickt
hat bei den Bayern funktioniert halt in
den letzten Wochen ich meine 20 Tore in
den letzten fünf Pflichtspielen wenn das
so weitergeht wird diese Mannschaft
nicht nach der Gruppenphase nach Hause
reisen wie die Vorgänger 2018 nach der
Blamage von Kasan und ich glaube schon
das große Teile des bayernblockes von
Anfang an Spielen werden theoretisch
könnte er alle sieben Spielen lassen
neuer die komplette Offensive und
dazwischen eine Viererkette ohne Bayern
Spieler weil außer Abwehr ist kein
Bayern Spieler dabei ja da wären aber
andere Leidtragende wie der Kapitän von
Manchester City ukai Gündogan Kai
havertz Jonas Hofmann also da muss der
Bundestrainer eine Balance finden ja wir
sprechen gleich über Füllkrug und Mokoro
das waren ja auch im Namen die gehandelt
wurden gleich Felix auch noch mal kurz
deine Meinung bitte zum Mittel ist
wichtig siehst du den bayernblock oder
würdest du sagen naja eben auch aufgrund
der Argumente die Thomas gerade
angesprochen hat mit günduan zum
Beispiel eben der ja dann außen vor wäre
also wie siehst du das wie wichtig wäre
diese Blockbildung
es ist ganz ganz schwierig ich glaube
das ist wichtig ist so ein Blog zu haben
und auch dass wir uns als Deutschland
sehr sehr glücklich schätzen können weil
fußball ist und bleibt Mannschaftssport
und die Jungs sind 24/7 zusammen da in
München und kennen sich in und auswendig
das sieht man wie gesagt auch jetzt in
den letzten Spielen mit der hohen
Torquote es ist enorm wichtig und das
macht schon Sinn das sind sehr gnabry
Thomas Müller aus dem FF kennt und immer
weiß wo steht der wo ist der es ist aber
wie gesagt auch schade dass halt ein
Ilkay Gündogan da erstmal so ein
bisschen nach hinten rückt ob er jetzt
spielt oder nicht will ich damit gar
nicht sagen aber das sind Weltklasse
Spieler die auch in anderen Vereinen auf
Weltklasse Niveau performen ja wo man am
Ende gucken muss spielt man mit dem
bayernblock weil sie sich gut kennen
oder spielt man mit der besten möglichen
Fußballklasse auf dem Platz aber ich sag
mal ob für eine Struktur für eine
Struktur in der Mannschaft ist der
bayernblock extrem wichtig und ja können
wir ganz viel von profitieren ja das mit
Sicherheit richtig dann gucken wir
gerade noch mal auf die beiden die ich
gerade angesprochen habe jusufer mukoko
vom BVB der wird am 20 November gerade
mal zarte 18 Jahrhunderte jüngste WM
Spieler in der Geschichte des DFB
eingesetzt wird wenn er eingesetzt wurde
aber immerhin darf er schon mal mit zu
dem Turnier fahren also bringt aber auch
seit Wochen eben überragende Leistung
muss man sagen vielleicht erstmal deine
Einschätzung zu mukoko also er ist
quirlig unberechenbar und hat am Samstag
mit seinen beiden Toren gegen Bochum ja
gezeigt wie torgefährlich er ist ich war
mir sicher dass er dabei sein wird auch
weil Timo Werner halt ausgefallen ist
vieles was das Tempo anbelangt was
werner hatte der quasi ein Stammplatz
hatte der hat 11 von 15 Spielen unter
Flick als zentralen Stürmer vorne drin
gespielt aber ich finde auch die
Entscheidung für Füllkrug völlig richtig
das siehst Du übrigens genauso wie
etliche Kommentar zu Ohren hier bei uns
auf Youtube Füllkrug völlig verdient
dabei das meinen also ganz viele
also dadurch aus Verständnis Felix für
dich auch für Krug zu Recht dabei
absolut also das ist jemand ich habe
gerade noch mal nachgeschaut zehn
Bundesligatore diese Saison es ist
jemand der gerade absolut performt und
auch der profitiert jetzt wahrscheinlich
durch den Ausfall von Timo Werner aber
es ist eine klare Schlussfolgerung
Niklas Füllkrug mitzunehmen ich mache
mir auch gar keine Sorgen
dass wir da jemanden dabei haben der das
Tor nicht trifft also der ist gerade in
der Super Verfassung und wenn du ihn
jetzt nicht mitnimmst wann dann also
du brauchst gerade auf der neuen durch
den Auswahl von Timo Werner jemanden und
wir haben mit Niklas Füllkrug jemanden
den andere Länder nicht mal eben so
haben also der muss mit sich genauso und
Felix wird 18 also noch ein ganz junger
Mann wie schätzt du sein Potenzial ein
ja riesig dass er so jung ist es
Wahnsinn ich finde das ist jemand der so
ein bisschen manchmal gelitten hat unter
haarland weil er halt wenig zum Einsatz
kam und jetzt durch den die Kader
Situation in Dortmund kommt er halt viel
zum Einsatz und das ist genau das was
ein junger Spieler brauchen nämlich
Spielminuten und du siehst was das mit
einem Coco macht auch die beiden Tore
jetzt zeigt wie viel Selbstvertrauen er
hat aus 25 Metern einfach mal zu
schießen und den den Ball unter die
Latte zu nageln also auch um Koko ist
jemand der gerade in der absoluten
Primetime ist den musst du mitnehmen und
dass er halt so jung ist macht das Ganze
umso spezieller Einnahme der auch noch
sehr jung ist und der nicht auftaucht
ist Florian Würtz der ist verletzt
gewesen ganz lange hat ein Kreuzbandriss
kommt jetzt wieder ins
Mannschaftstraining bei Bayer Leverkusen
aber das Turnier sagt der Bundestrainer
käme noch zu früh ja dann bin ich
komplett der Meinung ist halt auch bei
Marco Reus da ist es ja gerade zu
tragisch mittlerweile wie viele Turniere
er wegen einer Verletzung verpasst hat
und er hat jetzt wirklich
wir haben ja mehr Saisonbeginn war ja in
einer wunderbaren Form hat häufig das
1:0 für Borussia Dortmund geschossen
also wenn jetzt also der hat gefehlt bei
der WM 14 ganz tragisch letzten
Vorbereitungsspiel em 16 em 21 und jetzt
wieder also das ist wirklich der
Pechvogel der absolut also das ist die
Weltmeister haben sein Trikot
mitgenommen auf die Ehrenrunde also
2014 das kann man nur bedauern und der
tut einem Leid und der Bundestrainer
sagt er hat wirklich alles probiert und
das können wir zu 100% klauen Felix
deine Worte zu den beiden gerade
angesprochenen Reus und wird
also bei Flo wird setzt mich wirklich
sehr gewundert hätte man ihn mitgenommen
über die Klasse von dem Jungen brauchen
wir nicht sprechen aber er kommt halt
wirklich aus aus einer schweren
Verletzung ist es nicht einfach eine
Muskelverletzung wo man um tagebank
kommt kommt er zurück oder nicht sondern
ja eine Kreuzband Verletzung ist einfach
sehr schwerwiegend und da jetzt auf ihn
zu verzichten ist glaube ich für ihn
langfristig die beste Entscheidung auch
wenn es weh tut bei einer WM nicht dabei
zu sein und ja umso tragischer ist es
wie gesagt für Marco ihr habt es gerade
schon gesagt
wieder ein Turnier wollen nicht dabei
ist ich glaube auch er spielt eine
Weltklasse Karriere aber ein
internationales Turnier für die für das
Heimatland mitzuspielen fehlt auf seinem
auf seinem Karriereweg einfach noch und
man kann es ihm nicht übel nehmen aber
seine Gesundheit macht ihm wieder mal
einen Strich durch die Rechnung das
einfach schade ja sehr bitter für ihn
jetzt haben wir denke ich viel zum Kader
gesprochen auch zu Recht das war ja
natürlich heute unser großes Thema wer
fährt mit zur WM aber dann gucken wir
doch vielleicht gerade auch noch mal
kurz auf das Pionier und auf die Gruppe
in der Deutschland spielt die Gegner
also in dieser Reihenfolge Japan Spanien
Costa Rica Platz 1 und 2 kommen jeweils
weiter dann ins Achtelfinale das sollte
aber dann auch das Minimalziel sein oder
das ist sicherlich das Minimalziel weil
sie sagen ja sehr selbstbewusst das Ziel
sei der Weltmeistertitel der fünfte
Stern auf dem Trikot und ich glaube der
Weg wird schwieriger als viele glauben
Japan ist alles andere als ein leichter
auftraggegner man muss nur gucken wo die
Japaner spielen ich gucken nach
Frankfurt in die Premier League und
woanders sind in der Bundesliga die
laufen bis es nicht mehr geht und das
dauert sehr lange bei Ihnen und damit
kann man schon wenn man eine
spielbestimmende Mannschaft das Probleme
bekommen aber für die Situation wenn
Plan A nicht funktioniert haben wir
jetzt ja Niklas Füllkrug der dann in der
75 Minute eingewechselt wird der
Mannschaft den Glauben bringt das ist
noch drehen können wie Werder Bremen
dann fällt der Ausgleich und es geht
weiter ja das hat auch der Bundestrainer
noch mal explizit in Russland gefehlt
ein mentalitätsspieler der auch seiner
Mannschaft noch mal den Glauben wird
wenn es am Ende spitz auf Knopf steht
Russland bleibt der Freistoß von Toni
Kroos gegen Schweden wo man dachte jetzt
wird alles gut und dann kam Südkorea und
da fehlte Niklas Füllkrug in der
Verfassung von heute Felix wie guckst du
auf die Gruppe
ja du bist halt Favorit ne und äh in der
Position muss Deutschland genau absolut
klar aber ich meine auch auf Freitag
kommen ich glaube wenn man jetzt die WM
durch simulieren würde wäre Deutschland
auf Klaus Platz 1 oder 2 aber auch das
muss man erstmal bestätigen ich gebe
euch recht Japan absolut schwieriger
Gegner glaub der japanische Fußball hat
sich extrem weiterentwickelt und ja dazu
sagen das wird eine leichte Gruppe ist
alles andere als realistisch aber wir
sind Favorit in der Gruppe mit Spanien
und ich glaube wenn man Weltmeister
werden will und auch in die k.o Runde
kommen will dann sind das Aufgaben die
muss man bewältigen so das sind
Hausaufgaben die musst du machen klar
Felix weil wir gerade über Favoriten
sprechen du bezieht sich jetzt auf die
Gruppe aber wir können ruhig schon mal
den Blick darüber hinaus etwas weiten
wer ist denn für dich Favorit beim
Turnier insgesamt
da ich aus dem Social Media Bereich
komme bin ich auch immer eng mit meiner
Community verwachsen auch da kam schon
auf die Frage ich glaube das ist gerade
bei dieser WM glaube ich ein Land
schaffen kann was aus der eigenen Heimat
viel Unterstützung bekommt und ich kann
mir vorstellen dass das gerade
Südamerikaner sind weil ich da das
Gefühl habe dass einfach der Fußball
Gedanke so fest ist und einfach der
Blick auf viele politische Dinge die in
Katar gerade ablaufen nicht so stark
sind dass das nicht gut ist ist auch
gesagt aber ich glaube für den WM-Titel
und im Turnier Gas zu geben
ist das enorm wichtig deswegen sich
Brasilien so ein bisschen weit vorne
aber wenn man sich Kader von Frankreich
aber auch unseren Kader anguckt sind wir
auch absolut in der Lage das Turnier zu
gewinnen die Südamerikaner werden ja
eigentlich auch mal wieder dran ne 2002
glaube ich Brasilien das letzte mal
danach die Europäer dominierend das war
ja früher meistens auch irgendwie immer
so im Wechsel also die sind mit
Sicherheit motiviert wie siehst du wen
hast du auf dem ze passt das gesamte
Turnier angeht ich sehe es ähnlich ich
würde Frankreich in eine leichte
Favoritenstellung positionieren dann
vielleicht gleich auf Brasilien und
Deutschland ah ja okay interessanter
Einschätzung Felix dann kommen wir zum
Schluss der Sendung und wir haben auch
eingangs schon mal kurz gesprochen über
das Gastgeberland was natürlich kritisch
gesehen wird insbesondere auch jetzt
durch unsere
ZDF-Dokumentation aber vorher natürlich
auch schon die nach wie vor auch auf der
Mediathek für alle einsehbar ist da ging
es um die Geheimsache Katar sehr
sehenswert
Felix wie schätzt du das ein kommt jetzt
richtig WM-Fieber auf ist es bei dir
schon da oder hast du das Gefühl dass
diese anderen Themen außer sportlich das
ganze doch stark überlagern
also ich finde aktuell überlagern sie
ist und das ist auch in Ordnung das ist
auch richtig so weil es gibt viel zu
kritisieren an der ganzen WM wie es dann
wird wenn der Ball wirkliche rollt kann
ich nicht einschätzen ich kann nur für
mich gerade sprechen dass ich auch noch
gar nicht im WM Feeling bin gerade weil
jetzt auch Weihnachten auf uns zukommt
wir haben ein paar freie Tage über
Weihnachten ich habe mit meiner Freundin
jetzt Urlaub gebucht also es ist
irgendwie skurril das jetzt eine WM auf
uns zukommt
deswegen kann ich für mich sprechen ich
bin noch nicht im Feeling
weiß aber auch nicht wie es sich
entwickelt ob die Leute die auch gerade
sagen wir gucken die Spiele nicht ob sie
es dann wirklich schauen weil
Deutschland vielleicht auch weiter kommt
ein gutes Turnier spielt und dann dieses
Feeling doch aufkommt aber ich für mich
persönlich gerade bin nicht so richtig
in Stimmung dass ich sage ja in 10 Tagen
geht's los ich kann es kaum abwarten ich
denke das geht vielen so das geht auch
mir persönlich so obwohl ich natürlich
auch großer Fußballfan bin aber du
würdest für dich jetzt auch nicht
ausschließen dass du die Spiele guckst
nein das nicht aber das ist auch nicht
weil ich das ganze Support möchte
sondern weil die Liebe zum Fußball
einfach groß ist und mich der Sport
einfach sehr interessiert und auch
interessiert wie schneiden Spieler wie
Niklas Füllkrug ab also wie kann man das
Einschätzen die werden nach nominiert
auch in justify mich interessiert der
Fußball drumrum einfach ich finde aber
trotzdem gut das ganze sehr kritisch zu
sehen und uns auch kritisch zu
beleuchten nicht Supporter auch solche
Dokus und solche kritischen
fragestellungen zu allem und würde mich
auch freuen wenn während der WM noch
viel aufgedeckt wird was vor Ort
passiert und Sachen die vielleicht jetzt
noch nicht klar waren deswegen also ich
glaube es wird noch viel passieren und
ja auf deine WM-Stimmung aufkommt wird
man dann sehen Felix dann danke ich Dir
ganz herzlich dafür dass du heute bei
uns hier dabei warst in der Sendung viel
Erfolg weiterhin für dich sportlich aber
bei der SG Wattenscheid natürlich und
aber natürlich auch was euren
YouTube-Kanal angeht aber da läuft ja
bei freekickers richtig gut Thomas wir
hatten gerade noch mal Danke wir hatten
gerade noch mal über eben das turn als
solches gesprochen du wirst mit
Sicherheit das ein oder andere Spiel
gucken denn du bist vor Ort
Interesse weil letztlich geht es da um
Fußball und ich meine die die Spieler
die für Deutschland dahin fahren können
nichts dafür das vor zwölf Jahren das
Turnier nach Katar vergeben wurde da
muss man die 24 FIFA exklusiv Mitglieder
Fragen von denen glaube ich aus heutiger
Sicht nur noch drei unbescholten sind
nach den Ermittlungen die irgendwann vom
FBI und anderen angeschoben wurden
Platter sagt heute dass es ein Irrtum
war die da hin zu vergeben der hätte das
nicht erwartet ja ist Klang bei ihm so
als hätte er selber damit wenig zu tun
das war natürlich auch etwas skurril in
dieser Doku na das konnte man sich dann
in der Tat Fragen diese 26 Männer die
heute der berufen wurden vom
Bundestrainer können nichts dafür und
ich meine manche
waren gerade erst geboren also Coco war
sechs Jahre alt was kann der dafür
andere waren 12 oder auch Anfang gerade
mal 20 so ja tatsächlich mein Dokument
aufgänglich kann es gerade nicht sehen
ob er weitere Fragen von euch haben aber
wir sind eh auch am Ende jetzt unsere
Sendung angekommen wir könnten
vielleicht noch mal festhalten und das
hat ja auch Felix angesprochen das ist
natürlich auch wichtig ist und das hat
sich auch das ZDF auf die Fahnen
geschrieben dass man auch während des
Turniers auf die Missstände auch
hinweist auf auch den Blick hat auf die
Situation aus wenn wir mit einer sehr
sehr kleinen Mannschaft vor Ort sind
aber man versucht es eben so gut es geht
Thomas ganz herzlichen Dank gerne im
Studio du bist gleich noch im
Mittagsmagazin und kannst du auch noch
mal deine Einschätzung abgeben und wirst
das tun und wir danken euch recht
herzlich für die Aufmerksamkeit dass
also der WM Kader wir sind gespannt was
es bringt ne bei der WM die geht los in
10 Tagen kommt zu glauben viel Spaß
heute noch vielleicht auch bei der WM
wir belassen euch die Entscheidung jeder
entscheide selbst aber guckt oder nicht
aber
schon schwierig nicht zu gucken
danke euch einen schönen Tag und bis
demnächst ciao ciao